and some breaking news from the
Department of digital culture media and
sports to us here at Sky News confirming
that channel 4 will remain publicly
owned with reforms to boost its
sustainability and commercial Freedom
well in a statement the department says
the dcms Secretary of State Michelle
donalan has concluded her business case
review and announced that channel 4 will
not be sold instead the government has
agreed reforms to help Channel 4 grow
and better compete in the age of
streaming Giants Well the statement also
says plans include allowing Channel 4
the flexibility to make some of its own
content and a new legal duty to promote
long-term sustainability whilst
introducing protections to ensure they
continue to be an incubator for the
independent production sector it goes on
as part of this package channel 4 will
now commit to doubling its planned
number of new roles outside London and
doubling its Financial investment in
skills okay well let's take this back to
inking in the city with us on that
Amazon story uh breaking news there on
Channel 4 and what do you make of that
well we this was of course uh leaked
yesterday so we had an idea that this
announcement was coming from Michelle
Donald but I think this really uh goes
to the heart of the fact that there's
been a change of prime minister and a
change of uh cabinet personalities
Nadine Doris the former culture
secretary Michelle Donald's predecessor
was pretty keen on privatizing Channel 4
so was uh John whittingdale a former
minister with responsibilities for the
broadcasting sector and actually it's a
debate that's been going on for some 40
years 40 years Channel 4 launched last
year celebrated its 40th anniversary
last year and more or less from the
get-go that have been calls from various
people for the business to be privatized
the reason for the rationale that was
put forward by supporters of
privatization was that Channel 4 wasn't
big enough to stand on its own two feet
as a state-owned entity and that
potentially bringing in private Capital
would enable it to compete more
effectively with other players in the
private sector a lot of people they felt
that this was really ideologically
driven there was also a suggestion that
obviously with the public finances in
the state that they are that channel 4
might attract a fairly attractive price
tag some people that set as much as a
billion pounds and that would have come
in very handy for the government as it
desperately tries to reduce the size of
the deficit and bring down government
borrowing but I think in actuality there
were very few people who were prepared
to come forward and buy Channel 4 it was
very very uncertain as to whether there
would have been much appetite from stock
market investors and I suspect that's
the real reason why the the plug has
been pulled on this initiative